Do you have a favorite?
The quieter one
with the sugar daddy.
The sugar daddy got nothing
to [bleep] do with me.
$800 seems like a lot
for a radio, but I don't know.
Hey, how about we give...$400?
Really?
What year was the car?
We never found out.
Cut it in half.
Oh, dude,
I got the info right here.
All right, let's see.
Here. Well, see this first
if it's your pleasure.
What's the info?
Got it right here.
[ Lighter clicks ]
Wait,
what are we looking for?
I'm gonna need some more
of that thinking...
So it's $800.
...thinking powder.
Bingo.
Is this a stock radio?
Is it an aftermarket?
Wear and tear,
bad music, you know.
[Bleep]
$400.
Case closed.
If not, they're gonna
argue out there for two hours.
We don't have the time today,
Your Honor.
We got a full [bleep] docket.
You know what I'm saying?
I know.
I like that expression.
We got a full docket...
"Full docket."
...and a big, ol' [bleep]
jar of reefer,
so [bleep]
"We got a full docket
and a big jar of reefer."
It's 60 miles to Chicago.
It's dark,
and we're wearing sunglasses.
It was more than 60 miles
in "Blues Brothers," wasn't it?
I don't remember.
Yeah, it was a lot more miles,
I think.